pero es maravilloso tenerlo acá hemos
tenido una conversación increíble
siempre aprecio mucho la oportunidad de
compartir ideas con el presidente
especialmente disfruté en nuestro
momento el momento que iba con bella
noche en la visita la primera vez que
vine una cena Privada de Washington en
mucho tiempo
tenía la protección del gobierno francés
Entonces se sintió bastante bien bueno
Más allá de las bromas Francia es uno de
nuestros socios más importantes
históricamente también
pero es uno de nuestros aliados más
capaces a la vez
también se ha convertido en un gran
amigo el presidente macron edición
compartimos los mismos valores y tenemos
una agenda común
que se enfrenta a todos estos desafíos
de manera unida ocasionalmente hay
algunas diferencias ligeras pero nunca
de una manera fundamental eso ha sido
así desde que estoy en washingtonía
hoy reafirmamos la amistad de Francia y
Estados Unidos
junto a nuestros otros aliados de La
otan y de la Unión Europea el g7 todos
estamos Unidos y fuertes en contra de la
guerra brutal de Rusia contra Ucrania
hemos hablado muchísimo de esto de
nuestra reunión
mientras sigue nuestro respaldo hacia la
gente de Ucrania que defiende sus
familias y sus hogares
Y bueno
de esta agresión que ha sido
increíblemente brutal no podía anticipar
que iba a ser así de brutal cómo ha sido
lo que han estado haciendo muchos
reporteros en esta habitación estaba
aquí allí y saben cómo es hoy
reafirmamos que como dije Vamos a seguir
Unidos en contra de esta brutalidad y
Seguiremos con este fuerte respaldo al
pueblo ucraniano medida que defiende en
su familia en sus hogares sus hospitales
sus soberanía y su integridad
en contra de la agresión rusa y quiero
agradecerle a usted señor presidente
por dar
por la bienvenida que Francia le ha dado
a 140.000 refugiados ucranianos es una
marca de lo que son como un pueblo
Cómo reciben a un pueblo que huye de
esta guerra Bárbara de increíble
que puede romper la voluntad de todos
con sus ambiciones imperialistas pero
atacar infraestructura civil en Ucrania
disminuir el flujo de energía Ucrania
llevar los precios a un punto muy
elevado a acabar aumentar los precios de
la comida eso y era muchas personas no
solamente en Ucrania sino en todo el
mundo y él no va a tener éxito el
presidente macron y yo hemos resuelto
continuar en nuestro trabajo en contra
de las acciones de Rusia y mitigar los
impactos globales de la guerra de Putin
sobre el resto del mundo Estados Unidos
está ayudando a Europa a diversificar
sus fuentes de gas natural en el plazo
inmediato y mientras la transición
energía limpia seguimos trabajando en
una alianza bastante cercana con Europa
a medida que avanzamos
recibo con agrado del Progreso que
hacemos logrado en muchos de esos temas
a través de la fuerza de tareas de
seguridad energética estadounidense y
hoy nos hemos comprometido a profundizar
la cooperación entre Francia y los
Estados Unidos
sobre energía nuclear civil a través de
una alianza de energía limpia bilateral
en todo el mundo Francia y Estados
Unidos están trabajando para crear
estabilidad y seguridad
compartimos la visión la misma visión en
el lindo Pacífico
lindo Pacífico es libre abierto próspero
y seguro y vamos a seguir fortaleciendo
nuestra cooperación para defender esos
principios núcleos internacionales
particularmente en lo Pacífico la
libertad de navegación la libertad de
sobrevuelo empezamos trabajando juntos
para respaldar al Medio Oriente
para que sea más integrado más Pacífico
agradecerle particularmente el
presidente macron por su esfuerzo de
llevar el acuerdo
de frente las marítimas entre Israel y
Líbano también Hablamos del pueblo eran
Francia y Estados Unidos están
trabajando juntos para hacer
responsables aquellos que hayan abusado
derechos humanos
que hayan respaldo para contrarrestar la
respaldo iraní a la guerra de Rusia y
bueno ninguna guerra requiere al momento
nuclear mientras en los Estados Unidos
están buscando alojar
la próxima cumbre de líderes africanos
estadounidenses el presidente macron
entiende la influencia de África tiene
mucho que agregar Francia tiene
muchísimo que agregar en esta discusión
también vamos a profundizar nuestro
compromiso escuchando y trabajando con
nuestros aliados africanos fortalecer la
gobernancia la seguridad y las
oportunidades económicas en todo el
continente y enfrentar los desafíos
globales de nuestra era nuestra Alianza
también se extiende a en el espacio
exterior desde coordinar defensas
de nuestras actividades espaciales a
fortalecer los esfuerzos científicos
para monitorear el cambio climático a la
Tierra
tuvimos una discusión detallada sobre la
ley de disminución de la inflación Me
parece que fuéramos hablar pero estamos
hablando de esto Estados Unidos y Europa
comparten la meta de hacer unas
inversiones energía Limpia para
enfrentar los desafíos de transformación
energía limpia y construir leyes para el
futuro incluyendo
baterías verdes baterías con hidrógeno
estamos también coordinando los pasos
para coordinar nuestros enfoques para
poder fortalecer y asegurar la cadena de
suministro de manufactura y de
innovaciones en ambos lados del
Atlántico también nuestros equipos van a
hacer seguimiento a esta parte
mientras la consulta estadounidense y
europea continúa a pesar de nuestras
diferencias Francia Estados Unidos
también están liderando esfuerzos para
fortalecer la salud global a la
seguridad de la salud a nivel global el
presidente macron
estaba hablando de él quiero Resaltar
particularmente Nuestro esfuerzo para
llegar a esta meta de acabar con
una epidemia taria de que unos cuantos
años es una meta que vamos a sostener
para hacerlo Tenemos muchas metas al
alcance solamente tenemos que hacer que
terminar con esta pelea sea una
prioridad no solo para nosotros sino
para otras naciones por eso es que me
enorgullece entregarle la palabra
presidente macron
queremos construir a partir de este
registro de Liderazgo estadounidense
hemos reunido 27.000 millones de dólares
entre Estados Unidos y Francia como los
dos mayores contribuyentes a este fondo
global y Esto va a salvar literalmente a
millones de Vidas
si hicieron una lista en todas las áreas
de cooperación que tenemos entre Francia
de Estados Unidos estamos cumpliendo y
entregando un gran progreso Pero
estaríamos aquí hasta la escena
simplemente quiero cerrar diciendo y
resaltando nuestra inversión a largo
plazo para profundizar Los lazos entre
nuestros pueblos particularmente
el programa fullbright day Estados
Unidos y Francia que celebra su
aniversario número 75 que ha facilitado
miles de intercambios entre nuestros
estudiantes y nuestros educadores en los
en la última década Y eso ha sido
crítico para nuestra relación es una
parte clave para asegurar que el futuro
de esta Alianza siga fuerte vibrante de
aquí a muchas generaciones por venir
Muchas gracias de nuevo
por todo lo que nos están haciendo
juntas en temas de cooperación y
Administración
está construyendo su política exterior a
través de la fortaleza nuestra Alianza y
Francia está muy comprometido Muchas
gracias amigo Espero seguir trabajando
con usted y como solía decir
en el senado de Estados Unidos la
palabra es suya
Gracias Señor Presidente
gracias
[Música]
Que reflejan fielmente el intercambio
que acabamos de tener y por su acogida
fuimos muy felices con mi esposa
Compartiendo
con usted y su esposa y quiero decir
conmovidos estamos esta mañana mi
delegación y yo
de haber sido recibidos por usted en
esta primera visita de estado de su
administración
esta relación como lo dijimos usted y yo
esta mañana
se construye sobre una historia que va
más allá de nosotros Porque se construye
sobre sangre que ha sido vertida pero
también intercambios recíprocos a lo
largo de los siglos cada vez que las
cosas vitales y esenciales estuvieron en
juego estuvimos presentes el uno por el
otro
sin flaqueza y sin dudas y esto es lo
que debe estructurar el resto
desde el mes de febrero pasado en lo que
el presidente bailen describió
perfectamente es este espíritu que ha
dominado usted ha hablado muy bien de lo
que hacemos en Ucrania condenamos esta
guerra inmediatamente llevamos a cabo
todas las acciones diplomáticas para
condenar esta guerra y los crímenes de
guerra cometidos por Rusia en el suelo
apoyamos el ejército ucraniano en su
resistencia así como la población sí
quiero aquí sinceramente agradecer a los
Estados Unidos de América por la
magnitud y el tipo de ayuda que se ha
ofrecido porque esta guerra sucede en
suelo europeo nos afecta directamente y
ustedes decidieron desplegar muchos
medios para contribuir a este esfuerzo
colectivo nuestra conversación de esta
mañana nos ha permitido Confirmar las
iniciativas que tomaremos en los
próximos días y semanas para
reforzar aún más la ayuda que le
prestamos a las tropas ucranianas para
permitirles resistir también decidimos
de continuar actuando juntos para darle
las herramientas a la población
ucraniana para que pueda resistir la
lucha hoy se concentra en las
infraestructuras civiles
y estos ataques buscan quitarle la
Esperanza a la población civil y
convertir la situación en algo aún más
difícil por esto en diciembre
organizaremos una conferencia de apoyo a
la resistencia ucraniana y muchas
gracias por su apoyo en esta materia
señor presidente también continuaremos
trabajando estrechamente con el
presidente celinski sobre los diez
últimos los diez puntos que esté ha
propuesto y quiero subrayar el esfuerzo
hecho por el presidente celinsky para
abrir un camino de paz duradera al
tiempo que
está al frente de una resistencia eólica
heroica desde hace meses nuestra
posición no cambia ayudarle a Ucrania en
su resistencia no ceder nada sobre
nuestros valores conforme a la carta de
derechos humanos y acompañar a los
ucranianos y ucranianas en su territorio
cuando decidan reconstruir su país
cuando las condiciones lo permitan así
que me alegra ver que sus posturas al
respecto sean también muy claras Y me
alegra que estemos de acuerdo en
contribuir a la construcción de una paz
duradera también mencionamos las
consecuencias directas e indirectas de
esta guerra especialmente en cuanto a la
seguridad alimentaria y la energía
iniciativas comunes en el g20 y en el g7
van en esta dirección y lo volvimos a
mencionar conjuntamente esta mañana La
idea es ayudar a que los países
mitiguen las consecuencias de este
conflicto sobre sus economías
esta mañana tuvimos también
una excelente conversación sobre él
es la ley de reducción de la inflación y
las decisiones tomadas por los Estados
Unidos al respecto recientemente
efectivamente acercamos nuestros
enfoques y nuestras agendas para
invertir en las Industrias emergentes
críticas como los microconductores el
hidrógeno las baterías etcétera porque
compartimos la misma visión y la misma
voluntad
el presidente quiere crear empleos
industriales duraderos para su país y
construir una industria fuerte y segura
para su abastecimiento y nosotros
defendemos la misma visión y es por esto
que le dimos un mandato a nuestros
equipos para que continúen una estrecha
colaboración con el fin de encontrar
soluciones sobre las temáticas
identificadas y con una coordinación por
un lado los europeos y por otro lado de
los Estados Unidos para construir una
agenda conjunta para tener más empleos
industriales en los Estados Unidos y en
Europa y garantizar la solidez y la
resiliencia de nuestras cadenas de
abastecimiento
este trabajo
de coordinación con Europa es lo que
queremos hacer sobre prácticamente todos
los temas y usted lo ha recordado señor
presidente estamos también mirando hacia
el futuro
nuestros equipos han preparado
en distintos elementos para construir
una agenda de futuro y de esperanza en
distintos ámbitos en el ámbito espacial
con investigación exploración y también
temas industriales la energía nuclear
civil con
investigaciones compartidas sobre las
técnicas más avanzadas porque creo que
es razonable decir que tanto para
ustedes como para nosotros la energía
nuclear civil forma parte de la solución
energética en la que creemos que nos
permitirá también crear empleos tener
una energía segura competitiva y llegar
al objetivo de neutralidad en carbono de
aquí al 2050 también pudimos
intercambiar entre distintos actores de
nuestras delegaciones sobre tecnología e
Innovación tema en el cual nuestras
delegaciones han podido ilustrar el
trabajo que hacemos en nuestra agenda
común finalmente
también compartimos un compromiso sobre
los grandes temas internacionales que
son el fundamento de nuestra relación
Quiero recordar aquí Juan felices fuimos
de ver que usted tomó la decisión
conforme a lo que había anunciado su
campaña de volver a ser presentes en
grandes temas internacionales como el
clima o la salud esto cambia totalmente
la situación pudimos resistir durante
varios años pero ahora
arrancamos otra vez esfuerzos conjuntos
Y en este día mundial de la lucha contra
el sida
estoy de acuerdo con usted para decir
que efectivamente seguimos comprometidos
con la erradicación del sida de aquí al
2030 y nuestros dos países han
colaborado en los últimos años en la
financiación del fondo global del cual
somos los principales contribuidores
para luchar contra el sida pero también
el paludismo y otras enfermedades
continuamos
desplegando este esfuerzo sin descanso y
por esto estamos tan determinados en
avanzar conjuntamente en temas de clima
y de biodiversidad
y más allá de las innovaciones y una
agenda de soluciones climáticas también
lanzamos varias iniciativas durante esta
visita de estado construir soluciones de
financiación innovadoras para los países
más frágiles y en desarrollo para que
nos acompañen en este camino del
desarrollo y del clima y sobre este
punto usted tendrá un papel central en
la Cumbre que esperamos organizar el
verano que viene para lanzar una nueva
alianza entre el norte y el sur en el
marco de la lógica que lanzamos
conjuntamente es decir más medios para
los países del sur pero también
fortalecimiento de las instituciones
multilaterales financieras especialmente
reforma del Banco Mundial y mejora de
nuestra SIM de nuestros instrumentos
financieros existentes y en cuanto a la
biodiversidad lo pudimos hablar ayer con
el cocus competente
y compartimos una voluntad
de tener una agenda
extremadamente ambiciosa y trabajar
hemos conjuntamente en la preparación
del One Forest summit que tendrá lugar
al final del primer trimestre del año
que viene en gabón en África y yo sé que
esto también es de suma importancia en
su agenda con los países africanos que
acogerá Dentro de pocos días en una
cumbre en Washington y finalmente
Seguiremos comprometidos conjuntamente
luchando contra el terrorismo y por la
paz por supuesto quiero aquí
rendirle homenaje a nuestros soldados
caídos en combate en
cercano y en África luchando por la
seguridad de estas regiones
y quiero aquí nuevamente
confirmarle nuestro compromiso en
nuestra coalición internacional en
Oriente cercano y Oriente medio
seguimos comprometidos esta lucha no ha
terminado y es importante que todos
nuestros aliados y
socios lo sepan Este programa no ha
terminado y quiero agradecerle
nuevamente señor presidente por haber
aportado tanto en la lucha contra el
terrorismo en el sahel y en África
occidental esto nos ha permitido en los
últimos años y las últimas semanas
llegar a resultados sumamente concretos
se podría también hablar toda la tarde
al igual que usted mencionando todos los
temas en los que
colaboramos en la zona indopacífica el
océano Índico quizás unas palabras para
poner las cosas en orden estimado Yo
usted ha agradecido a Francia por su
ayuda
en el acuerdo histórico entre Israel y
el Líbano efectivamente
hicimos mucho pero son principalmente
ustedes los que han hecho el trabajo que
se merecía Así que muchísimas gracias
especialmente por el Líbano que es tan
importante para nosotros que necesitaba
este acuerdo más allá de los temas que
están en la agenda para las próximas
semanas y meses esto es señoras y
señores lo que les quería decir y para
terminar quería sinceramente
al presidente Joe biden
usted no es solamente un dirigente con
el que compartimos muchos valores muchas
luchas sino que tenemos conversaciones
muy francas respetuosas y comprometidas
sobre todos los temas pero también y
sobre todo es un amigo y
te quiero agradecer por la acogida
que
nos ha dado y por haber tomado tiempo
para tomar decisiones tan importantes
sobre nuestro futuro común gracias
bueno Muchas gracias
me referiré me he referido a este tema
en privado un cierre
de un tema con Israel
necesitábamos un cierre Y hacer que el
trabajo ocurriera entonces quiero
agradecerle a usted de verdad vamos a
recibir unas preguntas
vamos a llamar a dos personas un total
de dos personas
la primera
pregunta viene de afp
Quisiera hacer una pregunta a usted y
otra del presidente francés si pudieran
para usted en primer lugar está diciendo
que va a coordinar mejor especialmente
las políticas de economía verde pero
ayer Emmanuel macron dijo que la acta de
reducción de inflación realmente es muy
agresiva para las compañías europeas
significa eso que usted está listo para
hacer alguna excepción o alguna
extensión a la industria europea ahora
me pregunto usted señor presidente
usted va a
regresar a Francia con la seguridad del
hecho que los Estados Unidos van a darle
exenciones a las Industrias europeas
para hacer frente a los subsidios
masivos que se han votado aquí y de
manera más general Usted dijo que esta
iniciativa económica de Joe biden era un
riesgo de fragmentación del mundo
occidental no será más bien usted el que
quizás va a crear divisiones
voy a responder la última pregunta de
realmente no entendí nada va a responder
bueno miren
Estados Unidos
No pide disculpas y yo no quiero pedir
disculpas pues hice esto
Esta legislación la escribí pero de
ocasiones donde se escribe empiezas más
grandes
que tienen bueno sumas de 368 millones
de dólares es la mayor inversión en el
cambio climático en toda la historia
entonces obviamente va a haber algunos
desfases y va a haber una necesidad de
reconciliar cambios por ejemplo hay una
provisión que dice
que una excepción para cualquiera que
tenga un acuerdo de libre comercio con
nosotros y eso fue agregado por un
miembro del Congreso de Estados Unidos
que reconocen
no se trata realmente un acuerdo hay que
trabajar algunos temas de la esencia es
que vamos a asegurarnos que los Estados
Unidos sigan así como Europa
dejemos de confiar en la cadena de
suministro de alguien más somos nuestra
propia cadena de suministros y
compartimos eso con Europa y con todos
nuestros aliados y ellos tendrán la
oportunidad de hacer lo mismo entonces
hay algunos cambios que podamos hacer
para hacer fundamentalmente más fácil
para los países europeos participar o
estar por su cuenta pero eso es algo que
debemos trabajar no hay ningún no había
ningún propósito cuando escribí esta
pieza legislativa nunca pretendía
excluir a personas que estuvieran
cooperando con nosotros esa no era la
intención la intención era asegurarnos
de que ya no estuviéramos en una
posición donde ocurriera una pandemia en
Asia de China decidiera que no quería
vendernos chips de computadores nosotros
inventamos eso Entonces
mi punto es que estamos de vuelta los
negocios Europa también y vamos a
continuar creando trabajadores en
manufactura en Estados Unidos pero no a
expensas de Europa
lo que intercambiamos con el presidente
baiden y porque acaba de decir es lo que
mencionaba ayer
es muy sencillo los Estados Unidos de
América adoptaron una ley para sus
industrias y su país con un objetivo que
compartimos nosotros crear más empleos
crear oportunidades para la clase media
y acelerar la transición climática
la realidad es que
como lo mostró nuestra discusión el
objetivo de los Estados Unidos no es
limitar el acceso a sus industrias y hay
proyectos ahora en curso en el
continente europeo pero la diferencia de
financiación es tan grande que estos
proyectos están amenazados pero yo sé
que esta no es la intención del
presidente pude hablarlo ayer con
distintos senadores y representantes en
el congreso y Me confirmaron que esta no
era su atención Francia no vino aquí a
pedir cualquier excepción o exención
para su economía sino que vinimos a
hablar de las consecuencias de esta ley
y
la situación actual nos obliga a actuar
conjuntamente frente a los desafíos
mundiales tenemos que
sincronizar nuevamente encontrar una
dinámica positiva nueva porque tenemos
que trabajar juntos la conversación de
esta mañana para mí fue sumamente Clara
y de hecho sentí la misma intención
entre los senadores y los diputados ayer
es decir la voluntad del presidente
biden es de reconstituir aquí una
industria fuerte y
darle seguridad a las soluciones
tecnológicas para el futuro Francia
quiere Exactamente lo mismo para sí
misma y luchamos día y noche desde hace
más de cinco años para hacer lo mismo en
nuestro país lo cual nos ha permitido
frenar casi 15 años de
desindustrialización en Francia
recreando soluciones y empleos
industriales en nuestro país es lo que
queremos seguir haciendo por esto
decidimos conjuntamente con otros
europeos en la comisión Europea de
empezar un trabajo que debe ser ahora
técnico para que estos efectos dominó
que podían existir sobre los proyectos
que se están desarrollando en Europa
puedan solucionarse queremos lograrla
conjuntamente y no
oponiéndonos el uno al otro Es lo que
salió de las reuniones de esta mañana y
es la filosofía que comparto y es la que
necesitamos
Buenas tardes William Galilea para la
radio rtl
señor biden en francés decimos que no
hay amor sino solamente pruebas de amor
tiene usted la impresión que su amigo
francés se vuelve a su país totalmente
tranquilizado
para su país y sus amigos europeos y
quizás otra pregunta Señor macrón usted
ha puesto alguna fecha límite para estas
conversaciones económicas sectores
precisos en los que quizás espera
algunos ajustes de las políticas
económicas americanas
A ver quiero ser muy claro nosotros
tenemos un trabajo que hacer los
europeos sobre los semiconductores el
hidrógeno las baterías nuestra industria
Vamos a continuar avanzando como Europa
y no estamos aquí para
pedirle pruebas de amor a los Estados
Unidos sino para ponernos de acuerdo
sobre una estrategia y aclarar las cosas
que merecen serlo creo que lo hemos
hecho ahora nosotros tenemos que hacer
nuestro propio trabajo no podemos
pedirle a los Estados Unidos que adopten
una ley para solucionar los problemas
europeos nosotros como europeos tenemos
que ir más rápido más fuerte para tener
una ambición similar Y lograr además
trabajar de manera sincronizada y además
hemos aclarado que hay ya distintos
foros de conversación en curso y es en
las próximas semanas y meses que vamos a
resolver todo esto pero va a ir rápido
porque nuestros proyectos se están
desarrollando entonces creo que hay una
gran Claridad estratégica en los
intercambios de esta con la mucha
sinceridad mucha franqueza
así las cosas creo que las
conversaciones que tendremos las
próximas semanas en la comisión europea
en colaboración con nuestros aliados
alemanes y europeos en la comisión y la
administración americana nos permitirán
aclarar sin dificultad este tema así que
me voy
confiado pero también muy lúcido sobre
lo que Europa tiene que hacer
tengo mucha confianza
Esa es mi respuesta
bueno la siguiente pregunta por favor
Aquí tengo mi lista
mi turno de pedirle a alguien cierto qué
tal
Muchas gracias señor presidente
macrón
la cuenta para ustedes sobre Ucrania
pero en primer lugar presidente biden
los trabajadores de los trenes requieren
un día más de descanso como millones de
estadounidenses tienen si es así por qué
no negoció usted eso cuando estaba
ayudando a negociar ese contacto que
ahora le pide al congreso que imponga yo
negocié un contrato que nadie más podía
negociar
he estado intentando
que está ausencia paga este presente los
trenes pero los republicanos Siempre han
votado que no y dijeron que no era
posible somos de las pocas naciones que
no tienen una ausencia paga para sus
trabajadores no podemos permitirnos
Mientras tanto tenemos 40 y cinco por
ciento Un aumento en los salarios Hay
cosas muy buenas que están sucediendo de
hecho esto acaba con esa inquietud de
Bueno si hay una negociación en estos
días
hay muchos lo que yo estoy diciendo es
bastante claro lo que fue negociado fue
mucho mejor que cualquier cosa que ellos
ya tenían todos lo acordaron
hay cuatro sindicatos afuera de las 13 o
14 que si lo cortaron
cada vez que me pidieron que lo
presentara lo hice lo presente y todos
lo firmaron Esta es la historia no
significa que porque vamos a pasar esta
acta esperemos que aquí el viernes
de aquí al fin de semana
no significa que nos vamos a retratar de
una ausencia paga vamos a seguir
luchando por esto no solamente para los
trabajadores de trenes sino para todos
los estadounidenses
puede sorprenderle a alguno de nuestros
amigos europeos que no haya
una práctica así somos uno de los
grandes países que no lo tienes ya es
tiempo es el contexto en el que estamos
teniendo que resolver situaciones
los sindicatos lo han firmado
había cuatro sindicatos creo que 13 14
4 de 3 o 14 que no les gustó pero creo
que vamos a lograrlo no vamos a hacerlo
en este acuerdo eso sí no lo vamos a
hacer en ese acuerdo vamos a evitar esta
huelga vamos a hacer que las cosas se
sigan moviendo que los trenes sigan
dando y luego volveremos a obtener esta
ausencia paga no solamente por los
trabajadores de trenes sino para todos
los trabajadores
presidente macrón aquí en los Estados
Unidos el presidente va a Irene está
pidiéndole al congreso
o una patrocinio de señal de 38,000
millones para respaldo Ucrania ha habido
alguna reticencia por parte de los
republicanos el congresos diciendo que
no pueden seguir escribiendo un cheque
en blanco tiene usted confianza de que
los Estados Unidos puedan seguir
respaldando la defensa de Ucrania Cómo
han hecho en los últimos años de aquí en
adelante
Y acaso se ha hablado con el presidente
hoy desde tratar de urgir a Ucrania para
que negocie
el seguimiento de esta guerra
particularmente en invierno mientras los
precios energéticos
miren yo agradezco al presidente biden y
su administración por su compromiso
han hecho un trabajo increíble y les
puedo decir
que nuestras dos naciones
están o se componen de valores
históricas históricos
este asunto no es un asunto de un
pequeño país lejano en Europa es un
asunto de valores valores compartidos y
lo que escribimos conjuntamente en la
carta de las Naciones Unidas proteger la
soberanía y la integridad territorial y
es por esto que creo que el apoyo de los
Estados Unidos a los ucranianos en esta
época es muy importante no solamente
para los ucranianos pero también para
los europeos es por esto que Les
agradecemos tanto
pero también es importante para la
estabilidad de nuestros países de
nuestro mundo
si abandonamos este país amandamos
nuestros principios y por lo tanto se
pierde toda esperanza de estabilidad en
este mundo es por esto que es tan
importante que estemos comprometidos
creo que es fundamental
su pueblo sus representantes comparten
este objetivo vamos a seguir apoyando
directamente con apoyo militar económico
estamos incrementando nuestro apoyo
humanitario y para la segunda pregunta
que usted hizo
Permítame decirle que nunca le vamos a
obligar a los ucranianos que asuman
algún compromiso que no sea aceptable
para ellos son muy valientes defienden
su nación y defienden nuestros
principios también nunca vamos a
construir una paz duradera si no es
sostenible tenemos que acompañar a los
ucranianos hasta la negociación y la
firma de un acuerdo acerca de su
territorio y Su futuro
esta será la última pregunta
Gracias
señor presidente de
el presidente biden debe
hablar con el presidente Putin en los
próximos días usted también ha hablado
con él
usted quisiera saber presidente biden si
usted apoya el enfoque del presidente
francés y otra pregunta le parece a
usted realista que el presidente
selensky haya condicionado la apertura
de negociaciones a un regreso en bajo la
influencia ucraniana de la región de
crimea
mire solamente hay una manera de que
esto termine la manera racional Putin
tiene que irse de Ucrania en primer
lugar
parece que él no va a hacer eso
él está pagando un precio muy grande por
no hacerlo
está infringiendo
un terrible daño sobre la población
civil está
bombardeando hospitales hogares
infantiles
la verdad no se enferma lo que está
haciendo pero la realidad es que no
tengo planes inmediatos de contactar al
presidente putín presidente Putin
voy a elegir mis palabras cuidadosamente
Estoy preparado para hablar con el
presidente Putin
Sí realmente hay un interés de su parte
si está buscando una manera determinar
la guerra y él no ha hecho esto si ese
es el caso
en consulta con mis amigos franceses y
de verdad me encantaría sentarme a
hablar con él y saber que tienen en
mente y él no ha hecho eso mientras
tanto creo que es absolutamente crítico
lo que dijo Emmanuel
debemos respaldar al pueblo ucraniano
la idea
de que Putin va a vencer a Ucrania está
más allá de nuestra comprensión imaginen
tratando de ocupar ese país dos diez
cinco años y ellos
él ha hecho el peor cálculo sobre
cualquier cosa que haya calculado él
pensó que iba a ser recibido con brazos
abiertos por la parte
rusoparlante de la población ucraniana
por favor lea el discurso cuando invadió
cuando dijeron que van a invadir
nosotros dijimos
por favor lea su discurso él habló de
que él estaba donde necesitaba estar
él habló de la necesidad de que la gente
de quiebre es
la madre de la identidad rusa en su
principio etcétera él ha hecho un
cálculo terrible en todo momento la
pregunta es
cómo sale él de esa circunstancias en
las que se ha metido yo estoy preparado
si él está dispuesto a hablar
a entender lo que él quiere hacer pero
solamente lo haré en consultas con mis
aliados de la otra no lo voy a hacer por
mi cuenta Gracias
acerca de la pregunta que usted me hace
y las condiciones o precondiciones
impuestas por el presidente ucraniano
que lo más importante para todos
nosotros es que justo cuando Ucrania
está resistiendo está recibiendo
crímenes de guerra ataques contra sus
infraestructuras civiles y llevar
contraofensivas el presidente ha
propuesto un plan de paz en diez puntos
y creo que tenemos que trabajar con él
Porque existe una voluntad real de parte
de los ucranianos de entrar al campo de
las discusiones lo reconocemos lo
felicitamos
durante varios años fui responsable del
seguimiento de lo que se llamaba él
formato de normandía y la implementación
de los acuerdos de Minsk la última
reunión que hubo entre el presidente y
el presidente Putin que fue de hecho la
única fue en diciembre del año 2019 y
estamos en esa época con la canciller
Merkel le puedo decir que yo he visto a
un presidente sincero que quería de
verdad
conversar y el presidente desde su
elección hasta el mes de febrero no ha
querido sino negociar el que empezó la
guerra fue el presidente Putin fui el
testigo directo de ello incluso por
medio del viaje oficial que hice a Rusia
y Ucrania hace poco entonces
efectivamente el presidente tiene
condiciones para negociar ahora tenemos
que trabajar acerca de lo que puede ser
un acuerdo de paz y la evolución de las
próximas semanas y meses nos el cual es
el momento indicado y cuál es la
decisión de los ucranianos dicho esto
seguiré hablando con el presidente Putin
y de hecho hablamos esta mañana al
respecto con el presidente biden que
efectivamente no ha hablado todavía con
el presidente Putin y
queremos llegar a resultados muy
concretos y tendré una pregunta sobre la
seguridad de las centrales nucleares en
zonas donde hay combates especialmente
en la zona de saporicha Porque desde el
inicio del conflicto Recuerden que lo
hicimos en marzo para la central de
chernóbil apoyando el trabajo excelente
de la aeia y de su director el señor
grossi todo esto lo tenemos que seguir
haciendo
muchas gracias